all right you remember this guy right
here as Aaron Samuels the love interest
of one lilo and Mean Girls and out
Jonathan Bennett has come up with the
funnest cookbook I'm telling you guys
right now the bird cookbook Oh startup
it come on stop it this is a whoo all
right so talk to everyone about this
this is inspired by our favorite movie
of all time
Mean Girls right exactly how this come
about so this is a parody cookbook from
Mean Girls fans basically what happened
I was with a good friend of mine and we
were having guacamole and she tried it
and she she goes you know what that's
not regular block it's it's cool guac
and I go what what did you just say she
goes it's not regular guac it's cool
walk and I was like wait a minute we
need to do a Mean Girls parody cookbook
and so I called it my friend Nikki
Martin who's a chef it was a fantastic
chef from Food Network and I just called
her up when I said I have an idea I have
an idea what I love about is that if
you're a mean girl super fan I mean you
know get every reference in here and
they're sprinkled no pun intended all
over this cookware like every single
word it sounds like the plastics are
talking to you it's so fast this movie
really took on a life of its own right I
mean it's following you around
everywhere but it's like there's worse
films to be you know it's it's a weird
thing it's a weird thing to be you know
Aaron Samuels for your whole life but
and also it's an amazing thing I equate
it to being the Times Square ball and on
New Year's Eve because once a year the
whole world turns to the ball to watch
it like shine and glitter and fall down
and once a year on October 3rd October
everyone turns to me and is like what
day is it what day is it asked us what
day it is that's gonna be the one it was
the weirdest part were that they love
our beliefs become this you know and so
you know years later we still haven't
made fetch happen but we made we made
fettuccine happen that's right you know
you win some you lose some
what's your favorite recipe in the book
do you have one um I mean I love so many
recipes in here they're so fun um I love
Gretchen weiners also I love the
fettuccine alfredo fettuccine alfredo
because well what's the difference
between regular fettuccine alfredo and
fettuccine alfredo fettuccine alfredo is
okay I mean we have to be on brand guys
I think it's way too pink Alfredo
all right well I'm jonesing to try one
of these recipes I think we have Nikki
on the side your chef we have my
co-author oh of course she did oh not
just any quadrats I regularly it's cool
Nikki tell about it yeah what is this
like I love guacamole
and I love chips but this stuff is super
delicious that extra special because we
add apples and it's not the pomegranate
senior year so this guac like makes you
really pretty which we have in the mall
you have to try the guacamole dude I
think it is really fresh it doesn't have
a ton of garlic in it it's not spicy
it's like that's why it's called cool
block and take a bite you're like right
it's like super fresh yeah like really
really bright okay well Nikki Jonathan
thank you guys so much for being here
this guac is amazing yeah you guys you
can't sit with us you can sit with us
you can the burnt cookbook out October
2nd right October 2nd even if you
preorder it right now you go to burn
cookbook calm burn couple calm you can
pre-order it and then you'll have it on
your doorstep
on October 2nd so that way you can have
a pair of Mean Girls parties each other
time awesome guys what's yours to you
congratulations guys
[Music]